certainly a lot of the the scenes in
which they are involved are quite
heavily sexualized there was one
particular scene which caused a degree
of controversy a rape scene which some
had suggested while some of the accused
the series makers so the game of Thrones
series makers of of normalizing rape
does it concern you when you see your
source material receiving that that that
kind of reception well I mean no one
likes to be criticized I know the
controversy you were referring to which
is a scene that played out somewhat
differently on screen than it does in
the in the books obviously as the author
of the books I like the way I did it if
they had included I think some of the
the way that seemed played out in the
books it might not have been quite so
controversial hopefully that would have
been somewhat controversial I mean they
it was never meant to be a feel-good
scene even though I think it's a
consensual scene in in the books but
it's still a disturbing scene it's a
scene of incest that takes place in the
Sept where the son the dead son of the
two principals is lying in state prior
to his funeral it's always going to be
disturbing and twisted and problematic
and should be controversial you know I I
want people to debate some of these
issues and and to talk about it but
hopefully from the perspective as I as I
tried to get at in the books you've been
praised while you've been praised for a
number of the things within the books
but in particular you for the way in
which you've used female characters that
they've been stronger they've been
independent they've been as conniving as
the man I mean would you describe the
series as feminist in its content I
certainly believe that you know you
should you should have strong female
characters I'm fortunate in that I have
a large canvas
I have many many characters so I can
portray many different women who are as
different from each other as they are
from the men I can have courageous women
and cowardly women and strong women and
weak women and evil women and good women
and and so forth and that's the way I
think it should it should be there were
times in my life that I was identified
as a feminist and will describe myself
as that the feminist movement has has
changed over the years and there there's
some debate whether a male can ever
truly be a feminist so I'd hesitate to
use that term anymore because I don't
want to give offense to those women who
feel that no male can truly be feminist
and I am indubitably male but I
certainly believe in portraying women as
human beings and as strong and vital
characters in my fiction and I like that
in fiction by other people when I read
books by other writers have you been
surprised in any sense by the the
popularity of your books of the CDs that
flow from it but it's fantasy literature
that is color well I always thought that
there was a huge market waiting on
television and film for epic fantasy you
know epic fantasy since toki and
breakthrough in the 1960s has been
gigantic in the field of books one
author after another has has hit the
bestseller list at number one i'm only
the latest in a long tradition of that
but it's never translated to to
television or film until my first peter
jackson did it in film with the Lord of
the Rings series and now in television
with Game of Thrones and I think it's
because there was this perception in
television that fantasy was for kids and
a few people who attempted fantasy
always slotted it at like the eight
o'clock slot and they no sex no violence
don't want to disturb the kiddies but
fantasy in book form a cup fans a book
form is very much an adult genre
and Game of Thrones is the first thing
to really deliver that and you know the
audience was there as I thought it would
be but that being said the sure scale of
popularity has astonished me I mean I I
never expected that we would be the most
successful highest-rated show on HBO not
with landmark series like The Sopranos
and Deadwood and Rome having gone before
us I never suspected that this would be
such a global phenomenon that the show
would be popular all around the world in
cultures very very different from the
ones I was drawing on and when I wrote
these books which that kind of
popularity though can occasionally come
a of pressure to produce for example you
need an Edinburgh fit for the Book
Festival but a quick twelve through
social media and you'll discover that
many of your fans would rather that you
are at home writing and you find out a
straight thing to same extent I yeah I
do I do but first of all for every fan
like that there are hundreds who write
me letters saying hey take your time
we'll be there whenever you're finished
live your life and you know it's it's a
consequence of the nature of social
media that you get this kind of stuff
there's nothing gonna be done about it
but it it does get a little irritating
at times I mean none of its new it
happens whenever I do anything basically
when I watch a football game on
television or you know when I go to
visit my family in New Jersey and no
matter what I do there'll be people on
social media saying he should be home
writing